Wow big training camp oh my gosh my
Instagram my Twitter my BR at we're
going wild because training camp has
begun Simms men you are loud hold on let
me turn the volume up holy kid I mean
excuse me
we're both wearing our shirts you got on
your sim 70 I got my whoa big offseason
we just took some photos for the website
for people to buy good had a few
meetings this morning about the Sims and
Lefko football fantasy league shout-out
to meatloaf it's going great
go meatloaf how was your weekend pal it
was good we need to start doing Friday
and Saturday shows good good good Billy
to report just pay me a million more
they'll come up no problem you're
getting a million a million sorry I
didn't mean you didn't know that nothing
just lots of family crap really really
open up with training camps oh yeah of
course I mean I don't ever not be paying
attention to that stuff from yes or at
least like if I'm sitting at home having
in the NFL channel on watching like the
camp you know run around like one of the
training camp things in Atlanta one I
get really excited when I watch that
roof open it's pretty exciting who's
down there yeah but like it was just
weird they just watch I usually turned
off the volume too
I don't even want to hear what the
people are saying they're not great I
just I don't I just wanna feel like I
you know we study this this is what we
do and really in the weeks we are we're
very much in the weeds and I really just
watch the camp stuff to go well let me
see what this guy looks like oh okay you
know look at Matt Ryan don't know
football look at Brady throwing a
football right I might hear a little
context of what the conversation is by
but look at how skinny yeah good good
for him we wanted Big Ben to be skinny
they say great beans not beef but Ben
Roethlisberger been working out with a
personal trainer this offseason that's
like whoa big offseason like that's
genuinely surprising to you like I'm
carbs and sugar from his diet yeah and
said quote I feel better than I've felt
in a long time I'm definitely lighter
than I've been the last seven eight
years my joints feel great
and I'm just like Ben was probably
drinking milkshakes after every practice
I and this is gonna sound like I'm
taking a shot and I'm not because this
guy's awesome and I think he's in the
conversation from one of the 10 greatest
quarterbacks ever that's yeah I would
really question whether when the last
time Ben's worked out like literally
like yeah he might do the gassers from
time to time with the quarterbacks or
whatever they got it yes but like been
squatting or power cleaning or doing a
negative ghostrider
I think it's I think Eli Ben Flacco all
those guys you got it now they got a
workout to maintain it and how many
times are they gonna be asked you know
Tom Brady's approaching 40 and he's like
the best shape of his life well I know I
heard people to bagging on Brady though
towards the end of last week to about
like Brady's bod like oh yeah sure with
a shirt off okay he's 41 he's not like
perfect yeah he's not sculpted you know
people forget with quarterbacks it is
very hard there's a fine line okay
all right I'm gonna play devil's
advocate yeah okay but there's a fine
line in you know being lifting being in
shape and also being this ripped up Oh
super freak looking of a guy you don't
see any quarterbacks they look like
issues Dec Prescott Carson Wentz Mott
but these are young guys yeah my thing
would be it's not the exercise with
Brady it's the diet if I was so strict
that eating tomatoes was bad and the
only ice cream eaters avocado if I did
that for three days I feel like I'd have
Brady's I feel like I'd have abs yeah
you wouldn't so that's just Justin you
wouldn't after three days I can tell you
that you will not have abs
Brady's been doing this years and he
kind of had the dad bod he's 41 I mean
is he 41 this week or maybe yeah so I
mean look when I look at a guy like
Brady or Rothen or more ripped than
Brady
well definitely yes I mean that's
without a doubt is that just jeans no
it's not jeans but I also probably a
little more old school where I would
lift weights like that a little bit late
you know dak Prescott and Carson wins
like you brought them up yeah they're
Jack they're younger they're naturally
really big guys like yeah I don't think
they'd be that far off if they didn't
left away so they didn't nothing you
know
and they're just like that and be gender
with their shirt off
Eli or Brady I would think Brady okay
yes I would I don't know I never said a
shirt off Brady or Case Keenum
ooh I'm gonna keen I've been gone keenum
- yeah yeah athlete right athlete yeah
it probably has a little chest you
definitely like it's pretty good and we
know we know Cam's gonna win you know
Garoppolo is ripped
I would think I've seen a picture in
June's article and B are there you go
but I would think that's pretty natural
that's a guy that's just like in shape
does a little lifting but he's not in
there like body sculpting I guess I'm
gonna compare up to the older old people
yeah but anyway get back to Ben it's
it's exciting yes because he's been able
to do this without really trying which
is incredible on it's fitting credible
Ben's a phenomenal thrower the football
and yet I just think this is gonna be
it's gonna help Bend with movement in
the pocket getting at a you know dangers
away and then just buying himself a hair
more time to define people up and down
the field better with their shirt off
yeah Ben or Kyle Shanahan I think Kyle
really I think helps you think I mean
not anymore he used to he used to be
pretty ripped actually yeah yes but I
mean men I don't think that it doesn't
look like Ben's done a sit-up in a long
time speaking of Kyle Kyle got a care
package from Lil Wayne compliments of
the Sims aleph copepod Cal problem put
it on my tab
yeah so he gets it he sent him some sign
stuff
Lil Wayne included a message that said
I've only named one of my son's my name
the fact that you gave your son that
name is amazing yeah cent Carter or some
stuff also right did you see what Kyle
said in the presser though I did see
what did you hear what he referred to as
just some guy in a podcast someone on a
podcast playin mr. Chanin will played he
couldn't have called out Sims in Lufkin
could've been like this podcast I
listened to all the time you know my
best friend he sells NFL head coach okay
right and they're always trying to
squash parties or squash themes or
overall conversations and he also said
it was messed up yeah I know I think it
was messed up I
now it was not messed up and I know what
he means I mean yeah did I share some of
his private information yes I did to a
degree but I also know him well enough
to know that I could share that and he
wasn't gonna get really mad at humanizes
him I think he does he loves the fact
that he did get an autograph from little
Wayne certainly he's a truly a huge fan
so but he's still like just getting back
to that like yeah yes sir you know what
we're seeing we're seeing a transition
and coaching in my opinion for the first
time like the Bela check like curmudgeon
days sealed ones right like that's over
and if there is that curmudgeon like you
better win in a hurry or you're gonna
get fired like there's no way the the it
scene is not relating to your play
exactly right and there's a buzz about
people like Kyle Shanahan and Sean
McVeigh exactly right because of that
they can relate to their players they
get it they understand how the internet
works they don't always take themselves
too seriously
they can answer a playful question and I
know Kyle he probably just didn't want
to fan the flames and say or nay they
have another article written about you
know our friendship and I get that when
I read it
someone sent me the transcript at first
and when you read it that's funny when
you always have to see something before
you read it 100% it you would go wait is
he mad at me like that's why I like to
read the quotes though it's yeah cuz it
sounds like yeah it's like guessing like
let's see what he meant by that so it
just seems a lot more intense yes like I
actually think and we're gonna get to
this later
what dak said about the anthem stuff
when he first said he's like I'll never
protest whatever it was more of a
stutter into like I would never protest
like about that then like I'm never
going to protest but when you read it it
says never protest period yeah and
you're like wow that carries weight but
that's the thing right now with social
media what these coaches really aren't
realizing what a lot of people don't
realize that little quote gets put on
Twitter and then everyone runs with that
before you eat no one's listening for
the video right you the team should be
putting out the videos themselves you're
right that's what the Niners did with
Kyle Shen exactly right I am so we are
gonna be going in about a week or two to
go shoot some stuff for our new show
which is gonna be on YouTube which is
really just the Sims left go podcast
and it's like all the cool parts of it
and it's gonna be every Wednesday during
the NFL season I hope I'm not giving too
much information but we're hoping to sit
down with Kyle yeah and I'm just curious
if I put on a little Wayne's song could
I turn it off and him still get all the
lyrics yes really
oh he's he is a fishy annatto of Lil
Wayne yeah he is I want to get in the
Tesla with him and just love he's he's a
little my expert and there was a time
and place which he told about his story
about you know the Carter and the Carter
too and how he grew up with that because
he was at that time the [ __ ] boy for
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and breaking
down film and as usual just listened to
listen that why he was doing this thing
and that got him what a true listen to
when you were doing the Patriots oh
nothing I'm not a listen to anything
kind of guy I'm not I'm not
earphones in the gym anybody see me work
out in the gym nothing it's called
reality and I'm right there in it okay
that's where I am okay right in reality
right Lil Wayne I mean Lil Wayne little
Kyle Shanahan little Kyle look at his
press conference he was like oh yeah 1 &
2 was great and I'm still waiting on
five you know and I was like oh damn
you're really oh he's obsessed and he
could certainly throw out some lyrics
without a doubt I mean line for a line
just about it we're gonna play that game
with him yeah I'm gonna read him a
little weenie she was so annoying about
Lil Wayne back in the day like he was
the guy that was like wait did you hear
that verse right there and he'd really
apply it and he'd like have to sing it
along with say it slow he be like I put
it where I do go through all and then
and then he'd get done with that part in
fast forward to the next song and he
recommend that song was only in 30
seconds in can we keep the rest of them
one of the things that happened on
Wednesdays podcast that was in last week
you said they're probably gonna
restructure Julio's contract getting
more money they did just that hey the
auricle proud of you thank you
now he's getting 13.4 this season right
he's still under pastel underpaid right
there's no doubt I mean the people that
are in front of him the Mike Evans the
DeAndre Hopkins they are not Julio Jones
it's not a disrespect to that it's a
little bit like though Taylor LaJuan
just got a major contract the guy from
Atlanta Jake Matthews yeah I can't
believe he's being paid like them he's a
good tackle yes but he's not Taylor
LaJuan no but it makes Tyron Smith's
contract look really
ridiculous sirens in the 12s and now you
got solder from the Giants LaJuan and
Matthews in like the 15 right and I'm
going Tyron probably the best out of all
of them he's healthy yeah if he's
healthy it would take the Wong's
probably number one so Milan is in the
conversation for the best left tackle in
the sport right now in US and two he's
also what I think a guy like Mike Vrabel
and GM John Robinson the Tennessee
Titans love did you see how he came in
first precedent even see it but I just
know amine left tackle that sets the
attitude for the offensive line and the
offensive room together like guys like
Vrabel I think in a John Robinson look
at that and go like that you can't put a
price on that so they love that you know
the Tyrone Smithfield two left go but
wasn't that tenured that was a 10-year
deal right wasn't it
they'd locked him in for that that's
what they did they got him for the low
and locked him up forever do you want me
to look that up are you gonna be here
well I wanted to show you the Taylor
lawanna entrance if you watch this on
youtube you can check it out but here's
Taylor lawanda entering you're giving a
little audio here or do I have a muted
he comes in with like here check this
out
he has the rest of the offensive line
coming with him one of them is holding a
groundhog so the whole offense aligns
with him and he comes in in a full white
suit with a hat and a cigar for his new
big-time contract I did not see this
look at him he's like I don't even know
it's like that's what he called bossy
and there's a a Dallas or yeah Dukes of
Hazzard he was Boss Hogg he came in
there like that that's unbearable to
have a left tackle like that also think
about Tennessee Titans offensive line
they're always there for the national
Predators games like they are truly in
the community like you want to pay guys
like that yeah they are and Luanne's the
guy when there's a fight Luanne's the
guy holding it down no doubt about it
and and to be able to do something like
that you know what tells me more than
anything right there just from seeing
that clip of him walking out in a white
soup after he becomes the richest guy in
the team yeah tells you how much the
team loves him it tells you that's not
dividing that hey coach didn't care the
offensive lineman took part of it yeah
they let him go out there and kind of
make a fun spectacle cuz that's who he
is and they know he's all about business
those are the things I love to see yeah
and it's great to see a guy who's got a
little edge about him but he's really
good and yeah he's been kicked out of
some games and done some stuff like that
got rewarded huh isn't that funny O'Dell
isn't that Odell o to tell you
Odell please take the tail of one
transcript did you see the video of
Odell running into a guy and getting
contact and team drills I don't even buy
it I almost vomited makes me cry Tyrone
Smith eight-year deal for 97 million
just to let you know that looks so small
you heard to these other guys swindled
by Jerry George oh no lies down and look
hey Tyrone yes Jerry
Terra Jerry Jones we're gonna do you a
favor man what we're gonna get to that I
know I'm just well he did do him a favor
I'm not trying to you know that's
subject areas just cherry some other
contract stuff Peter King in his article
on the new NBC website tonight and the
football boring in there good morning in
two states
he agreed with Olaf cohere
oh did he he said I think this Aaron
Donald holdout could last into September
hmm easily yes he wrote easily right in
Douma consumed out and said that Aaron
Donald deserves a lot more money than he
got yeah that which is a good teammate
great team a good team and dominance has
been paid so he can appreciate where
Aaron Donald is he's real about it and
secure in his own self to go he's better
than me at this point of his career he
deserves to be paid though there's two
things that I think that play into this
factor right first of all Aaron Donald
in this kind of a conversation right you
both we could both agree if he's signed
to be the richest defensive player in
history we'd have no problem with sex
but that's a big landmark to make yeah
and to be asking to be paid the highest
paid defensive player in football teams
are there are like oh you're awesome but
man we're actually gonna have that next
to your name richest defensive player in
football the other thing I think they
can slow down progressions there is damn
they got some [ __ ] on that
defense and they're not gonna be that
desperate for anybody because they're
gonna just look at their team and go
well we got some ballers out here right
not like totally demolished also when
you're a defensive tackle it's not like
Sam Darnell who just got a new contract
or you had to learn the offense Aaron
Donald knows what he needs to do yeah
Aaron Donald will stay in shape if Aaron
Donald gets cleared two days before the
season I think it's fine yeah where
they'd rather he's there of course yeah
but him and Khalil Mack I think Aaron
Donald more than Kaleo Mack it's an
easier transition Khalil Mack just
because it's a new defensive coordinator
yeah Aaron Donal with Wade Phillips he
knows his responsibilities it's it's
you're exactly right there's there's no
worrying there from the front office
they're not like oh is he gonna remember
Wade's call when we call the three-four
defense next year and call you know the
Sam Mike bullets yeah he's still gonna
remember that's fine
you're right cool Mack there is more
there there's the unknown he has no
relationships with these coaches yet
they'd like to get that all started
they're trying to set a new culture yeah
in Oakland with him I do think that deal
gets done for like the opposite reason
we're just saying with the Rams first I
don't think Khalil can ask to be the
highest-paid player in NFL history
he doesn't hardware the job right up
there with it don't get me wrong
yeah but if they don't have Khalil math
that's a
the Raiders defense all right left go
that's the point where they're gonna
just go man we're an average defense to
begin with now you're not gonna get a
Khalil Mac our best player yeah our best
player on our team period out there
that's where I think it gets done at
some point and our other man-crush the
Texans are gonna let you devi and clowny
play out his current deal yeah I want
clowny to have 15700 I hope so the fact
that I still see people that don't give
clowny the respect that he deserves yeah
he is not only in the conversation with
Mac and Donald I could argue that he's
better than Mac and Donald in certain
parts of the game I'd certainly hate
ragdolls people more than those two guys
yeah I would say he went up there with
Mac he is he's more disruptive I think
than Mac is on a play to play basis he's
not as gifted as a pass rushers Mac you
know but you're right and he's like if
Olivier Vernon was also yeah true
athletic for yeah just like yeah quicker
longer all that Jadeveon Clowney is a
special specimen in left oh you're right
and we try to straighten people out here
he's one of the best defensive players
in the sport and two years ago I would
argued he deserved the NFL defensive MVP
and I know in that year I think he only
had like six and a half or seven sacks
but that doesn't mean crap that's he
always the year they went to New England
right yeah car game he returned the
interception against the Raiders for a
touch to us he did all kinds of crazy
john ross play he ran down john ross and
caused the fumble and ended john ross
season four to John Ross he is the
epitome of what we talk about with our
play the play ups that he kills it but
I'll say this
for his instance here in his case I
understand the Texans where they're
going here this to me is different than
Odell and Aaron Donald yeah because of
one he's had some serious lower body
issues yes
you know the Lisfranc injuries the knee
issue that sounds like it's Bona I got
it I know that they're gonna make him
see if he can go one more year right
shown he can be healthy when we were
about to start the podcasts and Arnold
didn't have a contract now he does have
a contract yeah but the issue that they
were fighting over was very interesting
which was if they cut Sam darn 'old
right Sam Darnell goes oh I want all
that money to be guaranteed yeah and the
Jets were kind of
making it seem like well this is our
backdoor clause if this doesn't work out
if you don't apparent bust after two or
three years we got you yes right and we
don't have to pay you anything
guaranteed and then I heard there was
also the talk of like the double-dip
what they talk about really if you get
caught and then the Brown sign you write
you get paid by the Browns out of the
gym yeah right yeah right and my
question though is you get drafted
number three overall mmm-hmm
in your words by a team that's been
waiting for you for two years and the
entire PR afterwards is the new face of
the New York Jets the new face the New
York Jets and then your agent comes to
you and goes listen they're worried if
you don't pan out they don't want to pay
you later to me that's gonna be hard as
an NFL athlete or any athlete to be like
we I thought you guys thought I was the
face of the franchise in the future but
you're not sure I know and then that's
where they use it against you your love
of the game and things like that where
you just go oh the hell with the finer
details let me just get out there and
play because I gotta get my teammates to
start leading the team and then three
years down the road you go man why did I
sign that just like Julio Jones is doing
damn I tried to do something right for
the team and they don't do right by me
so why would I do that
so yeah Sam Darnell I'm glad he they
drew a line in the sand and said no this
is what players have to do like Baker
Mayfield I think would you think what
the deal he wanted no it was that simple
got it fully guaranteed Baker I guess
was just so happy to be the first pick
in the draft that line right and and you
know again Cleveland that's they've had
that issue there it's been dicey where
they flecked quarterbacks they've
drafted go after the first two rounds in
fact their first two first-round
quarterbacks they've had they did the
same thing with if there's a team that
you need that language is a contract
it's the boy or the language of what
I've also heard his like suspension came
up with like Sam don't know if he got
caught let's just say in a car with
somebody with an open beer what we've
seen this day and age in the NFL it
doesn't really matter whether you're
guilty or not at the NFL thinks you're
guilty you're guilty and then you're
gonna lose guaranteed money so that's
bullcrap but back to your point about
what do you said about Sam darn old and
like the Jets so the team's our guests
are gonna take no liability for their
work and anything they have to do
anymore
we can pick whoever he wanted he's a bus
so what we don't want to be liable for
you had you've been the Jets knew they
were gonna draft a quarterback for two
freakin years
Sam Donald was
at the top of their list so now he's
gonna get there and if he becomes a bust
that's their fault they should have done
the research and that's what that's what
happens as part of the sport so I'm glad
he got a fully guaranteed yeah the the
whole thing with Sam darn old and and
Baker Mayfield was interesting but the
other contract that's going on is ro
Quan Smith so ro Quan apparently wants
the Bears to say in writing that they
will not take his guaranteed money
vii picking the giraffe to the Bears if
he suspended as a result of the new
helmet rule right the Bears apparently
do not want to set a precedent in this
Hansol holdout
like they don't want to start something
that changes the league but I completely
understand from Rome Khan at ro Quan and
his agents perspective this helmet rule
sounds real up in the air and to hammer
at home there was a number of quotes
that came from the Eagles yesterday
because the Eagles brought in officials
to say explain to us this nigel Bradham
great linebacker for the Eagles had a
great year last year explained that him
and his teammates felt underwhelmed
quote we were trying to ask questions to
get a better understanding and they
couldn't give us an answer they couldn't
give us what we were looking for they
were told listen if we see it we're
gonna call it and the players like well
what do you see and they're like it
depends on the official this is just me
talking for the best officials just left
and now we're gonna bring in this this
subjective call i watch college football
on Saturday every time it's 20 minutes
and slow motion was he bracing for
impact was he leading with his head and
now Rowe Kwan's going if I get suspended
for this and there can be language that
you take my guaranteed money away that's
not okay and I and the fact that Dave
wants that came out said he needs to be
in a camp why do we never interview the
players that were screwed by the team
why do we never interview the players
that were in former hold outs with the
front office we interview a guy that was
not that great of a coach and we take
his word for gospel that he should be in
Deva Watts that hasn't been involved in
the Bears in more than five to ten years
and yet it says it and then the
and base goes row Kwan's being selfish
he needs to learn how about the Bears
support the player they drafted admit
that this rule could be flimsy and go
you know what we're not sure how it's
gonna go we got your back why does it
never that side it's always the players
hurt on a team he should be learning
well the team who's made 255 million
dollars in revenue you can handle maybe
paying him a million dollars right I
don't know you're investing in the
future III don't you know and yeah it's
just this new rule alright there's a lot
of let's start on the whole Kwan thing I
mean he's a middle linebacker and yet it
sounds like right now is you know he
could tackle somebody like he's tackled
somebody nine million times in his life
and all sudden they can just throw a
flag and go oh you used to crowning your
helmet you know and we're gonna take you
out of the game and you're suspended for
a week or two
oh no more guaranteed contract what like
no more guarantees that that just that
can't happen I'm sorry it really to the
line for someone's opinion about what
you were intending it exactly right to
avoid a total guarantee or whatever that
may be
listen if they want to put clauses in
there like if you can arrest it on that
you know and do things like that I
understand that but because of a rule
change and your middle linebacker and
it's being used against you I don't see
how that works out and this rules
changed too I I don't I don't get it I
don't think anybody gets it at first
first of all did I hear right about
Malcolm Jenkins right that they're
saying in that same meeting they were
saying that I believe that somebody in
the meeting was saying his hit on
Brandon cooks in the Super Bowl he could
have been kicked out of the game if
people get kicked out for that hit right
there I am going I mean they need to
just stop the NFL they need to stop it
and just go to flag football and just
stop right now
forget it I will I will kill the NFL if
this is the [ __ ] they start talking like
Griffin and so I'm gonna be able to hold
it back to me that would be just
crossing the line stand outside fan
perspective I hear that it's it's funny
because it gets turned into you don't
care about the health and wellness of
the players but we're debating intent
whether or not you were trying to hurt
Malcolm was just hitting the guy right
that's what happens a lot of these times
you're at one level and then all sudden
the guy ducks down and gets lower and
also
you go well it was helmet-to-helmet
contact you're not allowed to do that
and the defender did nothing wrong he
was on the same playing field and same
level field of trying to hit the guy the
whole time and the offensive guy is the
one that lowered down to that level to
make it helmet the helmet context so
yeah it's um yeah it's concerning I I'm
really something that's peeking your
interest in going this could be really
Bo I mean it would just be another thing
with the NFL that I am NOT gonna want to
talk about next year I'm gonna want to
talk about the games right and this is
going to be it's good anytime it happens
it's gonna be leading everybody's
newscast I feel like it's the NFL did it
totally for propaganda to make just the
public go we're making safer right but
they don't really know what what it is
it was just like it sounded good lower
then no more lowering the crown of the
helmet rule it sounds sounds good but
there's no definition and and amend if
people start losing games over this and
stuff like that oh my god all right I
want to lighten up the mood a little bit
I got some photos and videos from this
weekend that I want to show to you okay
first one George don't worry about okay
so yeah this guy right here what's his
name damn Sammy Watkins it took me a
second
write me a second I knew he had his hair
chopped I did read that the holy cow it
makes this whole face look different it
I'm glad he changed it are you I were
done with the dress he needs a new look
he hadn't had any good luck with the
dreads really I mean I know he got 15
million things I had dreads I would
never get rid of them that is your
identity it's like when Tori Smith got
rid of them I was like I don't know who
you are oh my gosh you know my fear I
think dreads make people look faster
yeah because I think you have a trail
and so like your dreads go left because
you're right so it's like I don't know
make sure I saw the quote he said we're
gonna be a 40 minute 40 year old man
with dreads and I want to make yeah hell
yeah please don't be yeah I think you're
right second one look at the quads on
Leonard fournette so a lot of people
sent this to me and said bigger than say
Kwan question mark it's right up there
with it I don't because the one on his
left yeah I don't think it's as big as
say Kwan but again let's not
underestimate this freak of nature in
Leonard Leonard fournette
Leonard fournette and Ezekiel Elliott
are not far off the freak of nature body
when they
you said about both of them I've never
really seen a guy like this that's what
I mean I mean the Ezekiel Elliott has
ezekiel elias legs are bigger than four
nets Ezekiel Elliott I think would be
the closest Harrison yeah
Ezekiel when I saw him in person I'm
telling you if we tried to stick a
machete in him the machete is gonna Bend
before it goes into him he is like a
freaking rhinoceros with like wine the
rest that was my north Joisey coming out
but yeah he looks like he's got like
permanent protected armor on something
that happens every year the new freak
athlete at running back or defensive end
comes out and we completely forget about
the other ones it's like like miles
Garrett came out and we forget four
completely forgot about how much to
Davey and clowny shocked us yeah you
know and then say Quan comes out and
Leonard fournette was that guy yeah one
year ago yeah where the sports going
right now all right this one I'm going
to need some insight this is Dallas God
eart singing for the rest of the Eagles
Oh God
[Music]
you could tell he's nervous because he
keeps pulling down his shirt yeah all
right so what you did I don't know that
song yes you do
he's so off too and I can't even like it
seems to be memories sweet chairman
sweet child
sweet child of mine Wow yeah he needs
that he needs to pick it up a little bit
on that though yeah
what is your did you have to say
anything for the bucks did they have
like a talent show we always see it in
Hard Knocks I never had a sing I don't
know why I never nobody ever was there a
talent show I mean Oh always talent okay
okay
yes talent shows are absolutely
phenomenal too when when players come
out and make fun of you know the
coaching staff or another guy one of the
old heads on the show what did they make
you do oh gosh you had to do something I
I mean you know what I did I was mr.
Warren says personal right-hand man you
didn't have anything for the whole team
there's no embarrass me having to do
anything I don't I don't remember I
don't remember my other question yeah
you remember any rookie specifically and
what they had to do like what's the
first thing that come to your mind in
terms of rookie in front of the team
hazing was who's the first person I mean
I can remember like davon Joseph a
first-round pick yeah they make making
fun of the offensive line coach doing
things like that those are the best ones
when they made fun of the coach who
might have been quirky and says a lot of
crazy four-letter words and has all
these ways about oh yeah and then a
player gets to come out and do that I
can't was there ever a talent show her
you're like wow that guy's actually
there was good one Sam I wish you
would've warned me about this one - I
don't like to warn I know I know this
one these are ones I need to hare
warning because I I know there's ones up
what did Pacman Jones do team I don't
know yes that kind of hurts right I mean
I meant uh the the other guy a Chris
Johnson Chris Johnson CJ 2k I don't
remember him having that you know what
that I wasn't there during tre
can I get up I wasn't there either you
dumbass do you know did you follow my
career have we worked together for four
and a half years career geez
wait I know I'm missing some Melek I
remember Knowshon Moreno singing yeah I
feel like I remember Cadillac Williams
singing there was oh let me just think
Tennessee Titans that stuff help what
has great team camaraderie it breaks up
the monotony of camp it's the go like
damn are we really like the seventh day
in a row going into another team meeting
here at the end of two days and gonna
sit here and how to focus right and the
coach just spices things up by doing
little things like that for a few
minutes it's it is it's it's the joys of
camp
speaking of spicing things up yeah we
have a mole inside the Giants
organization not really but I did hear
this and G dot so apparently when Pat
Shermer came to the Giants yeah the
Giants no one in the facility no players
no no staff nobody is allowed to wear
red shirts it's only blue they're not
allowed to wear red blue only blue
getting back you can't wear red of the
facility and you can't wear black
sneakers or socks anymore who I like
that too Wow I don't care about the
sneakers or socks for the Uniting level
wear and the facility yeah I don't think
so it's all great the giant should be
white cleats and or gray cleats all the
way I mean I'm a fan more of white
cleats I think I always tell Kyle
Shannon like 49ers haven't won a
Superbowl since they got off the white
cleats and the Montana young heir and
he's like oh I like that uh-huh
so I hope he does that at some point all
right if he doesn't know where it came
from but man no red no red isn't that
their alternate jersey so apparently
they lost in those and Marisa no more
good I like it yeah yeah good go back to
the just get back to the blue and white
that's all I want to see for me the the
white with the blue in red on the
sleeves with the full Giants on the
helmet yes that's like my favorite well
I agree that's one of mine too other
thing is this is something that does not
talked about with that rumor
I love Pat sure I do too the one thing
that I find Hunt funny and I can't not
think about this
one with the Browns but yeah I know your
is pull up a picture of Pat Shermer okay
okay and then when that's up there okay
open up a new tab and pull up a picture
of Rich Gannon and tell me they're not
brothers from another mother because I
look at them sometimes and I'm like
that's the same guy all right so there's
rich yeah and there's Pat yeah there's
real as much as I thought no there's
just old white guys yeah okay you know
not all white people look to say okay
all right so let's do some funny quotes
this one is Michael Bennett on Carson
Wentz I can't we have this down there
that can just look now as he gets too
distracted Michael Bennett Carson Wentz
talking about him being healthy and
being injured he probably went to
Germany or Switzerland or some [ __ ]
because he looked good out there they
got that [ __ ] in Germany how do you
think Tom Cruise looks like that you
think he's doing regular stuff he's 55
and he looks like that
he's jumping off buildings he and
slowing down Bruce Willis he's still
getting it like the accusing is Rach th
you starting quarterback of a firm is
enhancing drugs I think I think
everybody in Hollywood that does those
kind of movies is yes they're all
I mean Mark Wahlberg's body does
transformations every year you ever seen
it it's like he's a dad and then seven
weeks later he's a bodybuilder then he
goes back to a dad and then you're like
holy [ __ ] he's jacked again and he gets
really dressed and I mean so but I just
like that Carson Wentz is being grouped
into the same group as Tom Cruise and
Bruce Willis like you just like that
Germany and get that old white guy still
yeah
I love Michael Bennet stakes on things
he's a man he is Saints head coach Sean
Payton our return game is kind of like
The Bachelor right now we have about 12
contestants all with roses we don't know
who our returner is gonna be and if she
doesn't like any of them we'll bring in
more I could tell you apparently watches
the batter do you don't know no I don't
watch any shows even though you could
have been the bachelor I could have been
the bet sir yeah that's right and I saw
men maids tale that's the one show I've
gotten into I like success I like
succession - I have - I have missed some
shows here and there okay I saw last
night I've seen a few I imagine that
succession is like what it's like to be
in The Sims family
exactly phil has this you're just trying
to overthrow Phil and then find some way
to screw them and take his money
good let's do it and this is my last
quote and this is not funny this is more
of we knew it
Jabril peppers Oh quote my mindset is I
don't know that version of myself last
year I can hardly watch tape of myself
so this year I don't care what I've got
to do I'm proving to everybody
especially myself what I've got to offer
it was a shock to him it was not a shock
to you but it was definitely a shock to
him until a lot of people last I'm
rooting for him
and I hope he does I know well because
he was the most overhyped guy in the
2017 Draft and I know a lot of people
were you know calling me a hater
whatever else I I always give my true
football evaluation I mean this is a kid
from Jersey I watched him play high
school football I wanted to say nothing
but good things about him yeah but yes
his problem and he's still gonna have to
prove it to me is what position is he
where does he play college football is
not the NFL yeah at Michigan he got to
play games against certain teams where
there wasn't another NFL player on the
offensive side of the ball so it's a
different level of competition take away
from Michigan yeah and this is something
that I always appreciate is you noticed
they were hiding him that's what I
thought man I don't think a team has
ever run the defense of the Browns ran
last year no with a guy that far back
yes and in essence they were hiding him
they were they were making they were
right you were they were like oh you
know where we gonna put him okay let's
put him 25 yards deep in the middle of
the field and it was not great no it
certainly wasn't I do know this the kid
is fearless tough and he works he always
has worked and always known that from
the jersey head coaches to the bleacher
report guys that used to go over and
film him in the weight room and he was
built beyond any kid that age he is a
guy I look at and go he's got to change
his body a little he's too thick and
muscular he's compromised some of his
speed and quickness you know because
these may be benched too much or done
too many curls and like we always talk
about the most of the NFL is in the
weight loss program where they're trying
to lose 5 to 10 pounds to gain a little
extra speed man so are we hope that he
turns it around
you really do we do um I got the MVP
favorite sitting in front of me right
now
I saw it I mean I know it's Brady it is
Tom Brady right you look at the rest of
the people not at all
okay who do you think is second to Brady
Brady right now is a +400 favorite I
gotta see I would say Rodgers as well
like plus 380 no he's plus 500 so it's
only when they grow up from now it goes
up sorry I'm going the other way so you
so he is number two Wow who is number
three I would bet against this one
number three it's not Todd Gurley Todd
Gurley is with Le'Veon Bell and Ezekiel
Elliott at 2500 to 1 okay they are below
it's all quarter but it is awkward Iraq
of course so number three is it's not
Big Ben no it's not
Russell Wilson Russell Wilson is not
even Russell Wilson is at number four at
1600 no number five at 600 Carson Wentz
is number three at +100 I bet against
tablet to Drew Brees is at 1200 Russell
Wilson Jimmy Garoppolo Cam Newton Matt
Ryan Kirk Cousins deshaun Watson hmm
it's a quarterback award of this day it
is it's become way too much of a
quarterback of award it's Von Miller and
JJ water at +10000 Antonio Brown is the
top receiver on the board at +4000 and
Rob Gronkowski is the top tight end at
plus 6600 man well it's just become like
I like Cam Newton at plus 18 hundred to
one well I don't know if I yeah I mean
Shawn Watson is the boomer bus guy the
JA deshaun Watson if healthy I mean the
Texans I feel like it all hinges on
deshaun Watson like if deshaun Watson is
healthy and at least like 85% or better
early in the season they're a team I
would go there like a secret Dark Horse
Super Bowl team but if they get off to a
bad start and he's not healthy they
could fall apart and it becomes a whole
coaching regime change hundred-percent
on the quarterback thing it is annoying
like with the MVP and I understand it's
it's a you know of course is extremely
important position and and the way it is
this day and age is even more important
but it just seems like everybody else
has to do something out of this world to
get in that conversation lives has got
to go 2,000 yards and you got to share
it yeah with James Manning JJ Watt had
that in
a year where he brought back like four
or something touchdowns and he was
literally the only guy on his team and
did he share with Peyton Manning - no he
didn't win it or was that the one he oh
that was the whole year we were arguing
that JJ watch is like he's really gonna
get it right and then he didn't he
didn't I know I can't remember who won
it but either way
yeah it's Brady it's the same thing with
the Heisman for the most part you know
the Heisman it's not quarterback - it's
really just here's the best player on
the best team you win the Heisman I mean
that's like the year I covered in Douma
can sue when he won every single award
at Nebraska I like the defensive lineman
the best offense of all that and he got
like third in the Heisman and that was
the closest I've seen a defensive player
getting to the actual Heisman ride the
fact that he got invited was amazing
yeah
that was the game I watched where he
destroyed Colt McCoy oh I know gosh now
four and a half sacks seven tackles for
loss and one no one said no sack at the
end that would knock them at I feel
little no no no he actually he was so
good that he's the reason we had they
lost the game he got there too fast too
fast let's call it first time I've ever
heard the rule that the clock stops when
the ball hits something right and
because Colt McCoy threw the ball and it
hit a railing yeah and you could see the
railing they stopped it right back let
the field will happen there were some
injuries Jason Verret akiles out for the
year man the Chargers just unlucky and
it's every frickin year
they've already lost hunter Henry they
lose rookie tight end Austin Roberts to
an ACL last time I checked the ACL
epidemic is up to eight which is around
where I said it was gonna be on
Wednesday
Jason Verret though out for the season
how big of a loss is that for a team
that we thought and still believe
probably could be a Super Bowl contender
uh it's it is a big loss I mean Jason
Barret you know we we haven't got to see
him a whole lot but his year I think it
was 2015 when he was healthy I mean he
has phenomenal coverage skills like
phenomenal I mean you know one of the
best man-to-man cover corners in
football when he's healthy but these
were the red flags about him coming out
of TCU undersized guy who'd been banged
up there and now what's this this is
three out of four years he's gonna mess
basically right am i right it's 2014 he
missed he played
2015 and then 2016 and 17 it was very
limited you know last year I know it was
none at all this year of course it's
gonna be none at all and I feel like 16
was only a few games but yeah I mean
that's a huge blow to a team that like
you said is extremely talented in 2014
labrum and rotator cuff tears in his
shoulders just six games 2016 partial
tear the ACL played four games 17 and a
week one loss acted out injured reserve
right afterwards and now this yeah it
just sucks because when you really do
look at their secondary if it could have
been Casey Hayward and Jason Verret you
go that's top five no that's a top five
cornerback you know with our man
gentlemen James and yes and then also
Desmond King Desmond King has shown
himself to be a really good player
Trevor Williams now will step up yeah he
is he's good Trevor Williams is good but
yes you're right it changes the dynamic
of their defense and gives them more
flexibility to mix and match personnel
sets during certain teams and that's
what kills me is both of their injuries
the big ones yeah Hunter Henry and Jason
Verret or both at positions that the NFL
is focused on right now and a tight end
that can do multiple stuff a corner that
allows everybody else to kind of do what
they need to do I'd call Pacman Jones
that's what he is
I've been texting with him really yeah
what's he saying he wants to go play for
a frickin team and play I mean did what
he says right now and be like are you
interested in the Chargers let's do it
right now on the show you said he had I
know he's interested with the Chargers
don't ya trying to make it entertaining
but I know I really do and okay but no
the point is if I'm the Chargers he
would be a guy I would look at this is a
lot like Jason Furman well I mean he is
definitely he's gonna add some attitude
to your defense
it's just weather I guess they want to
deal with him and maybe there's some of
the stigma that comes along with him the
thing I would say more to it than
anything too is pac-man coming from that
Paul Gunther defense right it's similar
in theory it was like you know it's not
the cover three press bail Seattle thing
but very similar in a lot of ways to
where I don't think it would be a huge
learning curve man in the Chargers
charge I really it's just every year and
I heard Floria on pft today saying
it's gotta be something with the
training staff and all that I will read
this quote and I this is kind of backing
up Florio as though maybe there's
something wrong with the Chargers we
celebrated John Harbaugh for saying
we're gonna take it easy here's what Tom
telesco the general manager the Chargers
said about Jason Vernon
quote he was healthy in the offseason
program and we were probably more
cautious and we had to be we probably
held him back and he probably wanted to
do a lot more we tried to gently ramp
him up just on volume but he's a
competitive player he wants to go full
go if you're going to play football
you've got to play full go to me
and I'll kind of put a little bit on
Jason there yeah where he's like Jason
wanted to go full go I guess so and you
know the first place I go with a guy
like that's like what's his list of
injuries can you list his injuries for
me it was shoulder it was on an ACL it
was a and now this is what Achilles yes
so yeah an Achilles ACL there's one
other one right one of those really is
another knee thing but but you know
again it shows I would also be
interested in just to see if it's the
same leg what it is you know so many of
these times this brings me always back
to the conversation about you know
trainers in the NFL and the physical
rehabilitation techniques are behind the
aid there was behind there times like
Monique abundant was just talking about
with Carson months you probably went
over to Germany or something like that
well I went to Canada because I couldn't
find anybody in America to help me well
let me see if these two two things are
different right are they the same right
it came out recently that the Chargers
do not have an analytical person on
staff none they're like the only team in
the NFL that have no analytics or if
they do they have one person something
like that okay it was just an article
that showed how far behind the times the
Chargers were Wow when I take that into
the count and then I think about all
these injuries I know they're not
related yeah but they seem related yeah
because if you're behind the times on
one thing I'm going to assume that
you're that on another right if you're
not gonna look at analytics which as I
talked about how we Roseman how heroes
one would use the GPS tracking of his
players yeah to worry about wear and
tear and how much they're doing that's
how they would use analytics sometimes
it makes me think they're not gonna be
up to date on the health as well
well it certainly don't assume no I know
but I know what you're saying yeah this
is your connecting dots and it seems a
little concerning that way I get you
yeah there's a lot of teams in the NFL
that are like that and it just thinks
because it's you know the Chargers are a
team that we look at and go man they
could they could go to the Super Bowl in
the a hundred percent then Jaguars
Patriots all those guys let's get to
whoa big training camp I sent you a
video that everybody was sending around
if Josh Allen overthrowing is running
back and everyone's like oh we still
can't throw but all reports out of that
camp are otherwise no [ __ ] reporters
saying that aj mccarron is quote playing
not to lose his job
Nathan Peterman has been the third
stringer but overall Allen has been
looking very solid for the Buffalo Bills
no smacks but everyone's go-to that
one-click course they are it's it's
Twitter it's the hater-aide it's soul I
got a I got a B I got to qualify my
statement because I don't know crap and
I said he wasn't gonna be good so I'm
gonna show you this one clip that he
missed the throw and then you know what
I found funny as he look under the
comments and there was a ton of people
defending him and showing clips of these
other great throws from the same
practice where I went wow that was a
great throw wow that's a good one
so it's glad I'm glad to see people how
they are in the comments yeah I I did I
do I wanted to see the reaction because
I figured okay with things like that is
usually like other Buffalo fans okay
maybe we'll see something for somebody
else whose watch practice and right
below there was two other videos of
great throws by Joshua yeah but nobody
wanted to talk about that the national
media didn't pick that up at all man you
know again it's it's a learning process
he's not gonna be perfect
no but I can tell you he's gonna make
jaws drop as much or any as that and in
any of these rookie quarterbacks coming
out jaws are dropping in Minnesota Sims
it was unreal how good Dalvin cook
looked in drill Saturday explosive he
says he's quicker and faster now to the
ACL surgery if you didn't see him you
wouldn't believe it but it looks to be
true iiiii saw that and then I also know
he's not wearing his knee brace right
there which I wish he would just for
training can do with just wear it just
do it
dartz yeah if you want to do it but get
used to the moons but he obviously feels
like he's tested it out ready to go and
I do think that's one of the non talked
about things with the Vikings a little
bit it's like an extra player they
picked up at a free agency you look at
them and what they did in free agency
it's Kirk Cousins Sheldon Richardson
right you and I both go they're still
gonna have defensive debt problems and
thanks for the second half part of the
season yes but we can also go damn they
didn't even have Dalvin cook down the
stretch there and you and I I think both
agree that he could be pretty special
yeah they did have Jerick McKinnon who I
think is gonna have a special year with
Kyle Shanahan but I look at dalvik and
cooking go you know how they keep those
defensive linemen not exhausted run it
with Dalvin cook a lot right yeah I just
I'm surprised at how quickly he's
bouncing back but that seems to be where
we are with ACL injuries without saying
this he's about eight to nine months and
you can pretty much get going again
pretty hard what was it like when you
were in the league with a seals I mean
it was like oh you're done for the year
it's you know 11 12 months from now but
what's even crazier is I can remember
like when my dad's era I mean when I was
you know I I was almost 14 years old and
my dad got cut by the Giants
I mean ACLs back in that day you were
done your career was over almost it was
almost like Dan his career is over he's
done Wow he'll never be the same and now
it's like ACL injuries you come back
Jerry Rice I feel like was the first one
to break down the barrier where he
basically said well there's mics here
but he basically he tore his ACL and
came back and played very early on I
think the next year and was ready to go
and said he would be and I feel like
yeah ever since then it's just gotten
quicker and I would also say that a
Adrian Peterson's recovery that was
insane changed the the the expectations
it and the way everybody because he came
back in like seven months and then ran
for 2000 yards was it right after that
that's what's insane about that that's
another level like he is the guy you're
right that broke down and we all go oh
you don't have to miss a beat anymore
after AC oh yeah okay well if you saw
Adrian Peterson in person you'd go damn
did they chisel him out of granite or is
that a real person that's also what I
was just
it's like here we are was say Quan
Barclay we've never seen someone like
this before
Adrian Pearson we've never seen the
other one no he's a different kind of
animal than a fournette Elliott or as
say Kwan oh he's a little bit more
leaned and ripped and shredded and just
this wiry dense cut-up muscle where you
just go man look at this country strong
like he's like one of those guys you
look up but you size him up and you go I
think I could take him but then if you
saw him do like one athletic exercises
back no I can't that's a that's a prime
that I'll never forget Adrian Peterson's
prime it was it was genuinely special
and that year when it was him and Favre
and he was just magical that his rookie
year in 2008 I believe they came down to
Tennessee and we played him like second
game of the year and I was like he's on
a new level and and I think you've heard
this story too I think the next year is
when my dad saw the person's memory
we've heard joseffer Christopher have
you ever seen Adrian Peterson in person
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
he's moving about Phil is he genuinely
believes he's like Christopher Columbus
like he's he's a guy he's like I don't
know if you've seen this guy Kurt Warner
it was pretty good so yeah it's Kurt
Warner last whoa big training camp whoa
Browns quarterbacks Tyrod Taylor and
Baker Mayfield have acquired an RV and
they've parked it on the premises of
training camp so they could have a top
secret Clubhouse only quarterbacks are
allowed inside and apparently a member
of the Hard Knocks crew wanted a
behind-the-scenes peek and Baker said
that's a sacred place what do you think
about their secret Winnebago it's cool
you like it I do like it I thought you
were gonna be acraman
well training camp I would think they're
using it just to go this is our
quarterback like we can sneak away here
and take a nap because you do you have
times where you truly have nap time or
they go like you got players you got an
hour off and do what you gotta do you've
eaten lunch we've had our first practice
now duty everyone do
now I unless he was at Denver I used to
sleep in the equipment shelves really
what yeah Yelp's the shelves the
equipment shelves you know although they
they have the shells that you can like
wheel together and wheel apart yeah huge
shelves that are like you know you can
make oh let me go forward yeah turn the
crank and it opens up and you would go
in there I would go in there and then
they don't end up for you we had
inflatable mattresses so I had an
inflatable like pool thing you know that
you float around my pool and I would go
in there and crawl in the bottom one to
have a blanket on and go I'm gonna get
45 minutes and then they'd I go close
the crank on me you know and they cry
could you just leave it like a little
inch of daylight in there and then when
it was time to get out I'd be like hey
hey no there's usually somebody the
equipment room it's funny because the
Browns are gonna be on hard but I do
like it and there's always something
regarding sleep texans JJ Watt was
sleeping in the facility Bengals Ojo
Cinco was sleeping there all the time at
night not even during the day right
but the Winnebago do you think they're
do you genuinely believe Tyrod and Baker
are liking each other's company I do I
think through I think Tyrod just from
like my brother played up in Buffalo
with tie-rod
I know tire I just being around him a
little bit is such an easygoing good guy
not gonna judge anybody
he wasn't our veteran edition of the
offseason and he's Chris incredible
self-confidence so he's not like
intimidated by any type of situation and
I think Baker Mayfield having been
around him and just watching him a
little bit he's the same guy I think
he's cool and he realizes like it's not
really about Tyrod Taylor if I go out
there and bawl out I'm gonna be the
starting quarterback right and I think
one thing there's a zero percent chance
that Baker starts the season I don't
know I don't think yeah I'm with you I
think it's 0-2 but I think that's the
only rookie crew they can go in there
have their own set of drinks maybe a few
snacks watch TV and kick back if they
want just get away from us left go PI
yeah they're really smart want to learn
football and then I think the biggest
thing is probably just taking the nap
but yeah the Winnebago then Winnebago
that's a smooth move and they just
parking in the parking lot you say yeah
yeah that's a good one I like
like that all right so let us go to a
few more things than we're getting into
this anthem slash cowboy slash Dez
Bryant ranch which I'm very excited
about first of all fans this is from
Jenner State sir day said just want to
let you guys know the winner of the Tour
de France
Jerome Thomas once had his spleen
removed after a crash and he came back
and won so he just wanted you to know
that people that have had their spleens
removed can still accomplish great way
yeah there's no doubt about it
look at me I'm here with left cow and
then also that's what I hear more than
anything the car-crash spleen though
that's what everybody always comes to me
what do you mean well most people lose
their spleen because they get in a car
crash and then the steering wheel oh
goes into their abdomen right and that's
the majority of times when I have people
come up I lost my spleen too or I had a
surgery crash yeah and they'd it's
always that we were in a car crash or
falling on the football like Chris
Mortensen what Chris Mortensen almost
died just like me cuz he fell on a
football playing football younger yes
yes spheal spleen was bleeding inside
and he ended up going to the hospital
that night instead of going to sleep
thank God and ended up yeah of course
living Wow yeah I didn't know that I
don't know where I came up with that
story but I did great I actually
commented under a video of Danny
Amendola catching balls with gloves and
I said yeah I'll be more impressed if he
could do without gloves a lot of people
got upset with me we have a great
listener I'm Frankie that sent me a
video of him catching it without gloves
which is great but a mime wrong to think
that those gloves are like cheating I'm
texting 11:00 what are you testing Oh
important NFL people that Crips for
instance you tell them you told us apply
in jail but I feel like this the videos
of guys catching balls from the jugs
machine it's not that impressive to me
because I've used those gloves before I
know I know I know the gloves are
cheating I think again I'm gonna say it
again
I think the gloves are a safety issue in
the NFL because of the ripping the guy
down by the shoulder tackle where most
guys if they didn't have the grip on
that gloves would fall off like when se
Kwang Barclay throws a stiff arm out
they just fall they would fall off in
the old days you can see that you see
Walter Payton or one of those guys do it
and you see their name and now with
those gloves you don't fall off and they
ended up being almost like wrangled like
a baby cow in the rodeo
yeah and they go down and they tear
their ACL like Le'Veon Bell with Montez
Burfict that would be the perfect kind
of tackle he dove in two hands and swung
around them and then landed on his legs
and it's not that he has great grip
strength it's because of serve
ridiculous I understand what you're
saying they are their [ __ ] okay they
make catching so much easier I kind of
want to move on to our training camp
tour throw a pair on and do the jug I
know so this is what I think you're
under us saying about this just the
special jug she's asked me right I don't
know I know that's what you're when you
see it in person and you're gonna go oh
wait this cool you see the holy cow this
machine's you're really close you're
catching it from here because he's gonna
be like the machine's gonna be where the
wall is and it's gonna be set at like 80
miles per hour wait wait yeah right
there yes that's that's where you don't
realize it that's like five feet away
uh-huh
it's flying and it's spinning just the
ball always go to the same spot they can
for the most part it's always in the
general area wherever they set it up yes
for the most part would you trust me to
put your head right there absolutely not
okay absolutely it would be fun you
should trust me I had the greatest hands
that we've ever seen what yeah not bear
the warrant said Oh better better better
than Morin I almost didn't Randy Moss
tell me do you think there's gloves we
had the best team hands on Tennessee
Titans but do you think those gloves can
like even if I'm not like ready for it
do you think it'll just like naturally
stick to it um yes I think what's gonna
happen to you the first few times you do
it is it's just gonna bounce off your
hand and you're gonna go damn okay this
is I got a like grip I gotta be tying my
grip out just a little quicker cause
it's moving so fast and spinning so hard
it's really just about let me focus on
see it
grab the ball so they're coming in so
what's high speed you think oh gosh I
mean those things can launch balls up
like 90 yards down the field that's what
they do they'll do punts with that and
the because the punter can't punt 900
balls in a row right so they'll set it
up and
yeah and yes why why does it need to be
that fast I think it's just about
training the eyes it's not using people
think it looks cool no it's it's about
it's about thinking of receiver okay and
you're you know you're you're you know
let's let's just say Antonio Brown and
you're damn I got to work this move and
make this cut I got to run a ten yard in
cut make this guy shake around oh I took
a little longer on my route let me snap
my head around purl the balls on me
holy [ __ ] right that's what you're
practicing so when you see the guys that
get really close and it's like it's a
good it's a cook so god is crazy they
turn their back and they're waiting for
somebody to Gail for them to flip around
and then catch it
that's right whoa whoa Oh or the guy
that sits there and they just keep
catching it one hand they play one side
just go home huh what's so crazy about
that it's just that's moving pretty good
and they become machines you're like
guys I go dial Beckham juniors hand we
saw that at the NFL yeah thing the other
day they're huge in Times Square
incredible strength in those hands
that's where I think it gets
underestimated they would have great
hands if they didn't catch with gloves
but yes the gloves take it to another
level it's a whole it really does feel
like cheating yeah all right speaking of
all right one more the story about Jon
Gruden apparently not speaking to Khalil
Mack do you believe that I I mean he's
spoken to him he said he when he first
got the job you know he say I'm excited
to work with you all that blah blah yeah
I do believe that he hasn't talked to
him Khalil Mack is he's not trying to
give the coaches any warm and fuzzy
feelings to giving them an inkling of
like oh he's close to coming back he
can't do any more from Rappaport is
quote I'm told there's no progress no
optimism no communication and the
holdout continues yeah they're [ __ ] I
know I got FL people texting me is
driving me crazy
nobody good that you can share with us
no I can't everything good though it's
good it's really good but the the Coolio
Mac thing I think we'll get settled here
in the next two weeks or so I do because
I think Gruden will go crazy and he's
gonna start nudging and going crazy in
the front office and he's gonna tell him
what don't we
what's still stupid detail that's
holding us back and he's finally gonna
talk sense into everybody in me like man
I mean come on he's her best player we
gotta get the mirror and it'll happen
give me that you have to get these
coaches I just can't
I'm not gonna go until you give me a
hymn I can't tell you give me a
conference nope
what nope cameras watching me yeah hey
whoever it was guessing my code a few
weeks back they were right when they
guess my phone unlock code yeah they
said it was zero nine twenty nine eighty
of zero eight twenty nine eighty it's my
birthday I don't expect to see any of
you people here to grab my phone and
I'll change my number anyways so there
you go guys
zero eight twenty nine now you know that
sims's birthday is gonna be in a month
August 29th yes and you're gonna be 52
52
all right let's get to this Dez Bryant
epic Twitter tirade Steven Jones went on
a serious NFL radio show and pretty much
blamed Dez for Dax struggles saying dak
is working on his game I think that last
year was tough with Dez in his ear I
think I'll have the year he had in 2016
if not better
and then Dez came out and said here we
go at the skate goat [ __ ] I charged
everything to the game and went the
other way you all know what the real
problem is don't put it on me with this
[ __ ] garbage ass play calling
everybody lined up in the same spot for
17 weeks he then continued a few more
times and said that Stephen Jones is not
clueless Jerry was the only one who was
clueless it was a plan to get me out
asked Travis and my brother Snake Lee I
mean Shawn Lee so he called Shawn Lee
snake Lee and then thought out with yeah
he's supposed to have been my brother we
laugh talked about goals and stuff never
thought it was a problem I got caught
first to know I found out he was also
behind it damn Shawn Lee came out and
said I had nothing to do with this you
need to take ownership for your actions
and all that stuff I'm sure you heard
all about this
what was your take when you heard well I
I mean like okay first thing is with Dez
Bryant like Shawn leaves behind it are
you crazy
meat
Tom Brady can't even tell New England
who to cut Aaron Rodgers can't tell you
you think they're like hey Shawn you
know we know you're like one neck injury
or a head concussion away from not being
on our team anymore who do you think we
should keep on the team I mean that's
just ridiculous okay so starting from
there I don't know what their riff is
either way I like how strongly came back
out of them
yeah be accountable for your action and
that's what he did
these are the issues you have when your
owner is the one being the spokesman of
your team all the time and your and the
owner son who's the GM right he's really
he's the guy running the day-to-day
stuff this day he's got he's really all
over it more than Jerry Jerry is just
there and basically I'm a to me what it
seems like on a topical way at this
point it's very nice to you but yeah I
mean I think those are the issues when
you're owners always going on the radio
and things like I think Jack Prescott's
development yes last year wasn't as good
as we had hoped
but to think that like then one of the
Jones family really felt like Dez Bryant
wouldn't get that wouldn't get back to
him when he's still living in the Dallas
area was talking about this I know but
he's such a big hot-button topic there
but then added to that I will defend him
and say yeah their offense lacks
creativity a little bit like we've
talked about too much are they dependent
on we're going to dominate the line of
scrimmage and DeMarco Murray and Ezekiel
Elliott are gonna run for 150 yards down
your throat and you know okay great but
there's a few times when that doesn't
happen you need some creativity in the
past game and that's where they did hurt
Dez Bryant and Dez Bryant did just line
up outside in the same spot which was
also hurting him in his free agency
right because nobody's seen him do
anything else really right
and they did kind of screw him over by
letting him go so late in the process
they screwed him over right so his wide
receivers coach was Derek Dooley and I'm
telling you I watched the All or not no
one thought Derek Dooley was a good
coach before here okay he didn't really
do anything in that room I'm just saying
that when I watched that all or nothing
with Dez Bryan Dallas yeah when he was
freaking out let's say in that
Washington game he's freaking out
because he had single coverage and the
offense was let's keep it simple right
in front of us and he's like dude take a
chance every time Dez freaked out on
that show
it was productive yeah here I'm telling
you look because you actually got to
hear it right and it was come on let's
do this I'm seeing an opening it was
never give me the ball was never the
know it was about the team man that's
all I've ever heard I mean whether
that's from Jason Garrett or anybody
they've all said the same thing usually
when he was going off on the side of
them it was nothing about me me me it
was us we need to do this bah blah blah
it was always some point last year's
injury no the wreath last year on Dez
Bryant is insane and think let's go with
the fact that you had a running back
that missed six weeks and when he left
your season fell apart because he was
accused of a lot of things off the field
and the fact that the first seven eight
weeks when he could play you didn't know
if he was playing until Wednesday or
Thursday right so that's number one yeah
to DAC took a step back in his
progression and it's okay to admit he
was not that great of a thrower the
football he didn't look as smooth yeah
probably because his running back wasn't
there that tire and Smith was injured
for the first time they lost number got
there are so many reasons why Dallas and
for the VP to drag Dez into this that's
wrong is unnecessary it's like blaming
your ex for everything no no no no maybe
you are sloppy cuz you're sloppy right
and and I look at the Cowboys and I go
my issue with the Cowboys continues to
be the Jones thing I'm telling you what
other owners are down there in the
Monday morning coaches meeting going
linebackers coach what do you have to
say wide receivers coach get out of
there I know I know it's your team I
know stop micromanaging but there'd
acting GM too so it's a little different
I can't get mad at them for wanting to
get involved in their billion-dollar
investment
it's annoying at times like this is I
don't mind them being down there in the
team meetings and stuff like that I have
more of a problem with them doing radio
interviews for every Dallas Network that
calls and oh here I'm gonna tell you
everything about our team once again
that's where I look at listen des
Brian's not the guy he used to be you
and I know that we talked about that a
lot last year like when he's one-on-one
he's not a slam-dunk to just run by
people anymore that day has come and
gone he probably was frustrated because
he did get left on one-on-one and he had
a quarterback before this and Tony Romo
when he saw one-on-one he just men man I
must find some way to get this guy the
ball with the creative back shoulder
throw or whatever it may be
and DAC desin complain about that the
first year at DAC because they were 13
and 3 and the number one seed in the NFC
so everything went good the last year
went off the hinges the running game
wasn't as dominant and he's going yeah I
can catch some of these balls I know I
met look like I'm covered whatever it
may be but now the real thing is is
where do you think he goes okay I know
you've been doing research well I mean
just where nobody teams you come up with
I have no inside info like I really
don't the teams how many took out a
month I think that seven teams that
maybe make sense to me okay okay
these are Sims as seven teams that make
sense for Dez Bryant number seven I mean
no specific or thank you okay the browns
of course browns of course yes
Corey Coleman who knows Josh Gordon
double who knows Jarvis Landry needs
help
yes could he go to Cleveland number six
the Panthers the Panthers boy him and
Cam Newton will be a dynamic duo relying
on rookie DJ more maybe but their
leading receiver is a running back I am
Devin fudge this man may be right as
bright I haven't done yeah that could be
an interesting combination if yet Brian
and Pontius on the outside you like Greg
Olson all sudden you go home so there's
a team I look at and just go I think
they can handle the personality yeah I
think the offense is not overly creative
and cam he can your cover he'll quarters
wants the OC of Dallas could they get
the Dallas receiver Chris Sims stole
that from Lefko who totally said
Carolina early in the process number
five
I'll throw the Seahawks out there as a
team right shuttle Seahawks they've
already taken a flyer on old retread
Brandon Marshall just kidding Brandon
new friend of the show Doug Baldwin and
Tyler Lockett could that be a guy he's
used to a scramble drill with Tony Romo
nobody scrambles a you know the
Cardinals number four the Cardinals
whether it's Sam Bradford a Josh Rosen
larry fitzgerald needs help exactly has
moved on and who's the number two heck
who knows I'm being serious I do not
know who the number two receiver is I
know they need help who is it JJ Nelson
number three that's yeah it is I think
it is I got a look now I'm actually
getting a little scared ISM there's
their number their number to receiving
threat is David Johnson they're number
three is probably Ricky seals jokes hold
on I seriously got a look it's actually
driving me crazy I'm looking it up and
you're a little slow
Chad Williams is the number two also Oh
Christian Kirk they just drafted at
Texas A&M right yeah and they signed
Bryce Butler out of Dallas damn but no
Chad Williams was the guy that was
running offseason drills with Ojo Cinco
this offseason
JJ Nelson go JJ Nelson went to Alabama
Birmingham but he's on their rosters
though yes okay good that's what I got
scared of I was like this is their
number five behind Larry Chad Williams
Cristian Kirk Bryce Butler okay yes
Cristian Kirk is probably the fantasy
guy to turn man I just yeah that's
that's not a real impressive group so
that makes sense to me too okay and then
number three or is that number two
number three I the Colts the Colts
yes they have T Y Hilton sure they no
longer have Donte Moncrief do you like
Jack Dooley Doyle
not that much who else do they got there
nothing impressive freedom tell you I'm
gonna read them all to you right now of
course you said you said him they have
casein Williams Ryan grant right from
Washington good receiver right they paid
a lot of money drives the kid from
Clemson Deon Cain my question is you
know their GM does he fit that what that
GM wants to bring in probably he's gonna
scare them I think too it agrees he's
gonna scare teams because they're just
not sure what he is exactly but I just
look at them and go when they added Eric
Ebron so that I
I believe that the Colts with Frank
Reich are gonna be doing a lot of the
Eagles meditativeness
sets with Jack Doyle and Eric Ebron
they're gonna have their receiving
running back like Naima Hines who you
really like toward in Wilkins and Marla
Mack but I look at it no they could
absolutely they could use it certainly
yeah but I don't think that's a big
house if he fit yeah okay anthers makes
a lot of sense right I
and this is I threw all teams out there
they just felt like so this is this
number two number one well the number
one but it's no specific order it's just
the way I ended up writing them down but
like the steelers thing is interest i
think that the steelers secretly have a
hole at receiver and everyone's saying
it's it's not that much of a yeah we're
gonna depend on tony obray rogers who
tore his ACL in the playoff game they're
really relying on James Washington
yes rookie out of Oklahoma State right
Darius Hayward Bay you know what San
Antonio no it's juju but you know Darius
Hayward Bay is nothing more than a
number four pretty much and I don't know
what you're gonna get a James Washington
I know that you're not that high on him
I'm not no but I look at that team in
Antonio Brown just asked for him to come
up it makes sense to you it does I mean
it makes sense to me in in a more in
terms of he has a quarterback that he
can't talk over he has a wide receiver
that he's not better than and he's got a
head coach which is the ultimate I just
need your positive energy and if you're
gonna be crazy focusing on the field I
think he's a perfect fit for business i
I agree I I think there's a lot of
positives there in that situation too
and I also look at it as one of the
situations where I go like I think if
you look at all the situations and we
just went through Dez Bryant shoes ago
what is the one where he could go and
really be a positive contributor and at
the end of the day when the season's
over people are gonna go Jenna Ryan had
a good year and he was positive for that
football team like the Steelers are a
place where I look at and go he could be
that guy because they're gonna be in
they're gonna be in the thick of things
we know that if he has some big catches
and some big moments and all sudden like
you said Ben's talking good about him
and everybody abies talking good about
all of a sudden the perception gets
changed and he gets paid paid the next
year yeah so from that for just from his
standpoint alone I look at that
and the Panthers I think and probably
the Seahawks to go well that's also the
three best quarterbacks of the team's
you named I think Ben plus Dez could be
really dynamic just his ability to throw
the deep ball I will also add personally
yeah I am now ready to say I would like
the Eagles to sign Dez Bryant you good
huh here's the reason he would slide in
it you're number four which I don't
think des will be willing to do
al Shawn's the number one I think that
Nelson is above des at number 2 Mike
Wallace has a specific role as they take
the top off guy and des would be over
Mac Holland's who Mac would play more
special teams but I think about it like
this red zone Alshon on one side des on
the other side 5050 let's go I know with
all the guys plus he gets to play Dallas
twice a year yeah I think with this last
Twitter rage couldn't you see him being
more motivated remember when he first
became a free agent he said I'm going to
the NFC East I just don't think I would
love the Eagles I don't think they will
I don't think so either I think
Washington makes some sense but they're
gonna roll the dice with Paul Ricca
their jobs I had unlike the the edge of
this conversation is that where the
Vikings okay which I know they have some
solid stuff there right and with Filan
and our digs but I'm not gonna sit there
and go oh wow that's an unbelievable
group there he could add something there
and the other one I even looked at was
the Detroit Lions I just thought just
from the pure receiving standpoint I'm
surprised you didn't say Green Bay I
only reason I didn't is just Cobb
Davante Adams they got Jimmy Graham and
I don't really put myself in their shoes
to go well if they didn't want Jordy
Nelson I don't really understand like
why why they let him go and then get
this guy that doesn't make sense to me
my big teams as I said when he first
became a free agent was the Panthers and
the Bengals and their angles are a teen
I think could still use them it's AJ
green and then it's Brandon LaFell
and then it's the man John Ross so I
look at that and go that's another team
that allows you to be yourself really
every AFC North team except for the
Ravens because they sign all those guys
Steelers Browns Bengals could all use
they could all use them you're right it
would it would fit too I he's gonna get
signed by somebody here soon somebody
and then about after preseason game
number two or three somebody's gonna
look at their team and go okay it's
official yeah we don't have that third
receiver or another guy that can you
know create create some place for us
talking about Dez talking about the
Cowboys talking about this national
them everybody must stand or they're not
going to be a thing I also think DAC and
Zeke both had quotes in which they were
like I'm not going to protest I'm not
gonna do it we're America's Team blah
blah blah blah blah there's also this
notion of reinforcing following the
Joneses with Dez Bryant and how they're
treating him hey guys we're telling you
that if you don't get up on that line
you're off the team and then they're
almost reinforcing it by when we cut you
we're gonna drag you through the mud
you're not gonna assign to another team
do you think there's any chance that Dez
Bryant and how they're treating him is
reinforcing their command to the team no
I don't I look at this more than
anything and just go this is this is
what the Cowboys are and who they are I
mean when you go to the Cowboys they
sell you the Cowboys we're the Dallas
Cowboys we're America's Team we're the
nothing in the state of Texas and they
get everybody to buy into there's a
special place to play there's no doubt
about that
I mean it'd certainly be one of my top
picks for organizations to go play for
because of that star on the helmet and
everything that goes along with it but
they get you to buy into what they are
Tony Romo cowboy
he got Dez Bryant first round he was and
the Cowboys all in you know here's dak
Prescott Ezekiel iya the Jones have
taken them under you're the face of our
franchise just keep doing everything
right be the stand-up guy
so they're drinking the kool-aid and
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with them not making a
stance I'm not gonna sit near him you
don't have to protein you don't have to
protest right and I think the line
they're just I'm never gonna protest but
I really implore people listen to the
audio of it and I might just find it
right now because it didn't sound like
I'm never going to pro two shirt and
again I'll say mine my two cents about
this once again is I mean we have to do
something about the social injustice is
the world like have to it has to be
there still has to be attention focused
on that at all time and you're gonna say
that we got to find a different way to
do it but now hon tio comes out and says
that Jerry Jones is being a bully and
stripping players of their rights and
chance to participate right and Dez
pretty much came and confirmed said you
really think I wanted to be
you know doing that with Jerry Jones
last year and doing all he didn't want
to do that either yeah but he did it
just like everybody else on the team's
gonna do it this year so why didn't he
stand up then so don't you know that you
should have done it the Jerry Jones
Trump relationship Kaepernick's lawyer
Mark Geragos has said it's a partisan
political issue I have proof of it but
I'm under a protective order people
don't actually understand what's
happening behind the scenes with the
Cowboys and the president it does seem
like Jerry Jones has been fighting
battles for Trump when you really look
back at it yeah definitely when Goodell
was going through the stuff with Trump
Jerry Jones sued the league when Trump
made a comment everybody should stand
Jerry Jones came out and said my team's
gonna do it it really seems like right
now and this is just Kaepernick's lawyer
kind of putting it out there there is an
alliance between Jerry Jones and Trump
and and it seems and look they took all
their phone records and he said I'm not
allowed to say anything because I'm
under protective order but I know some
things and it's against the law yeah so
it I don't know man it I could I
couldn't as a player I'm not an NFL
player was never an NFL player it would
have a hard time knowing that this was
happened I know and having my owner
applaud it if I did not support what the
president was saying right the NFL
player and me and most of these NFL
players i yeah I want to be like you
know okay yeah [ __ ] you then I'm
kneeling sorry oh you said I couldn't
kneel Jerry sorry I'm kneeling like yeah
you're talking about a bunch of guys who
are alpha males that don't want to be
told what they can do right with their
freedom and things like that so that's
gonna bother people only thing I'm
pushing it back is the same thing I
always push back ratings were down I
don't want to see the players get hurt
and ultimately they're the ones that are
going to get hurt here
because mr. president is going to change
the story as usual and nobody nobody
even knows the story anyways so we just
got to go we got to find something else
my thing is if you don't want to tell
them to stand up in the anthem Jerry
Jones fine but start figuring out a
frickin solution and some progressive
thoughts of what you're gonna do to get
some of these things out that the
players are concerned about yeah
and that's what has to happen players
are gonna have to start really sharing
their personal stories and some of the
gruesome things they've seen happen I
really think it's this I think with the
the protesting during the anthem and
this anthem policy which is going back I
think that beak when it started the
conversation would go you're
disrespecting the flag I'm trying to
bring awareness and I think that the I
don't think that our society has
officially come up the way of supporting
the players in this fight for awareness
and to fighting this to the claims that
are very factual that of police abuse
towards african-americans but now I
think what's happened is the shift is
not they're no longer kneeling for
awareness I think it's almost become we
are now kneeling to disagree with Trump
yes I because the Trump has now made it
oh you're standing you support me and I
think that it's we've always talked
about him hijacking and ambushing and
all that but I really think now players
in a really precarious situation because
now if they stand out there Trump is
going to claim victory and some of these
players are gonna be like in Russia and
these poll that's not a player that's a
country that's doing your rhetoric yeah
but I'm saying that these players are
going to they don't want to be seen as
okay I'm gonna try and clear like this
well if you talk to an athlete and you
say what's one thing you want people to
know about you that you want to say I'm
more than just an athlete but now if
they stand there since no one's
listening to these guys after the games
that action is now speaking for them and
they're trying to go I'm not happy and
this is an action that I'm being forced
to do and I don't want to do it because
I don't agree I I think the whole
bringing awareness people like Malcolm
Jenkins and a lot of these players are
continuing to fight the fight I don't
think that the NFL accomplished enough
with their little action they haven't
done anything though the NFL in the
NFLPA there yes that's at the end of the
day like what you're saying like it's
not about society either I mean yeah
sure Society can contribute but they
gotta find a way to figure it out the
NFL in the NFL PA got a finger are you
gonna make everybody stand that's
fine but you better have some avenue to
where some of these stories get out and
the players can tell their size for me I
remember the Browns last year when they
came out they played a video of all the
work they've done in the community where
police and all that stuff for me this is
a part of NFL games that is going to get
very awkward at the end the national
anthem and what I think you do is before
the national anthem every Tuesday there
should be something done to bring
awareness to this some form of in the
community some form of society and that
video is played on the TV before the
anthem it's not during the anthem but I
need a five minute feature about
something the team is doing to bring the
community together and now that we've
shown you we're bringing awareness now
we're going to ceremonially stand for
the anthem I think the troubling thing
with the anthem is this when you do
something your entire life it feels
weird to suddenly stop kids when I was
growing up kindergarten first grade
second grade third grade when the anthem
was played you stood and you did it I
wasn't for me I wasn't like thinking
about the country it was just because
it's ingrained in you and I think that
it's it's upsetting to a lot of people
but I think I'm not hearing the next
steps I'm hearing you don't know why
they're doing this and you're being
unpatriotic and we haven't gotten to
that third layer which is what are we
actually doing it's the same thing over
and over again
I know but college football is not in
the field for the anthem really
yeah they own American I don't know must
be an American see for me it's not even
American on American I think I think it
gets down to this thing now which is the
most interesting which is the Trump
Jerry Jones connection which is is this
man acting out the wishes secretly of
the guy of the president who has been
openly waging war with Roger Goodell in
the NFL the NFL has told Jerry Jones no
more talk about the anthem ever but as
we talked about before it's really hard
for him not to say anything it's really
hard because he's the most important
person in that statement that's mine
right I mean he's gonna get fined he's
broken out he's breaking an NFL rule the
rule says that you can't they just set
the rule you get if the play
to stay in the locker room they can but
he's telling them no so why doesn't he
get fined I don't understand that why is
that I already been levied mmm that's he
needs to be fine for sure yeah he's
breaking and I felt protocol like if
you're gonna hold the players to the
letter of the law we're gonna suspend
players because they duck their head by
accident as they were getting hit by a
Mack truck then man the owner who's
breaking the rules in plane day and just
throwing in the NFL's face paper fine I
hope also I we've had a lot of fans
anytime we have a discussion like this
some will reach out and say thank you
for having civil discourse I disagree
with you guys a lot right but I
appreciate you having the discussion we
we have been very open about where we
stand but I think with this discussion
so often it gets turned into right or
wrong I don't think there is a right or
wrong I think that there's just not
enough listening and there's not enough
discussion behind your unpatriotic and
you're not listening and III don't know
what I would do as an NFL player right
now because they are the ones that are
under attack and every Sunday they're
gonna be the ones that were watching and
judging and critiquing and all the
people in the stands are free from
judgment and the owners are free from
judgment and the front office is free
from judgment and the training staff and
everybody and the only people that we're
gonna be watching or the 53 who comes
out of the locker room late who's
kneeling who sticks up their fists
that's definitely not gonna go away I
mean yes I mean the president's gonna
tweet about it like once every two weeks
for sure so it's a distraction
yeah it's you know we're ending our show
with the anthem because I know how a lot
of you guys feel about it but you know
if if there's ways for solutions you
know what we could be an agent a change
is out there I'd love to hear him yeah I
I would love to hear them too you guys
come out with great ideas yeah I think
that would be something cool because I'm
legitimately sick of talking about this
like I've actually hit my end like I'm
like man I've had it and like I'm just
so I'm going to open myself up to the
audience I want to open myself up to you
that's where I get scared because I am I
get tired of it too I get tired of
hearing the same points but I also know
that when you stop voicing your opinion
is kind of the
that's the reason you bring it up every
week in every two weeks I love football
you love football I want to do a show
where we just throw footballs at things
like that's really what I want to do
yeah this is high level [ __ ] this is CNN
MSNBC Fox News [ __ ] that I don't watch I
don't I read certain people I check
things out but like I [ __ ] read
football 24/7 and so do I feel qualified
to talk about this [ __ ] all the time I
really don't I do but at the same point
that's good for you I'm really proud of
you watch all those you're gonna get to
eight you're gonna get to this age where
you gonna go man when did I get watching
the news is fun years old that's fine I
was a news reporter yeah so I know how
much of it is [ __ ] yeah like oh my
god yeah I just I I sympathize for the
NFL athlete because I don't know what I
would do
I really don't if I was someone that
really believed in certain things and
felt like I had to stand up and I was an
alpha male that my entire life I've been
celebrated for my pursuit and my undying
you will it would be really hard for
four grown men to go see I told him to
do that and then someone being like yes
thank you for falling in line that'll be
really hard it would be really hard and
there you know there's only there's only
a handful of players I think in the
sport that could really change the
overall perception of the you know
Donald Trump and his supporters and all
that - and I do go back to like when you
hear some of the players talk about you
need some of the white stars to speak up
like I mean if if JJ Watt or Aaron
Rodgers are Tom Brady started to speak
up I think it would bring in a whole new
listener to the argument to where they
go huh if Aaron Rodgers started every
press conference with I'd like to bring
up an example of something in our
community that is good that we're
working on or something that is
happening that is upsetting and I'm not
gonna answer football questions until we
do something on this I don't know if it
will work I don't know either I like I'm
gonna try I know all right that got a
little heavy we will be back on
Wednesday of course Sims and I just
found out we're going on a little road
trip
next Wednesday might actually call the
road addition yes
oh man back to life the Golden Gate
episode if we're out there oh man
lost in the history of time the annals
of time
josh has his two buttons unbuttoned a
shallow taco meat whoa big Monday first
Sims peace out homey forfend Rick good
evening and for the lef koe man we
appreciate you guys we love you hit us
always on social at Sims and left go
slide into the DMS if you're nasty and
we will holler at you guys SL FL y'all
are the [ __ ] we'll talk to you later